a busy working mom has ways to stay on
top of things
Sadie has perhaps an unexpected one
she's big on nootropics
that's the buzzword for a new generation
of substances taken to make users think
faster
remember for longer and concentrate
harder this is my supplement cupboard
that I've been using I actually started
off with just the one drawer but slowly
what's been happening is I've been
getting rid of all of my spices and I'm
actually taking over nootropics could
technically be anything from caffeine to
unlicensed medicines or psychedelics
Sadie though sticks to legal and mainly
natural compounds usually what I do in
the mornings to be honest I'll just make
a decision how I'm feeling and what it
is that I actually want to do for the
deal for her the supplements have become
a useful tool it really needs to be on
the ball all the time I'm a mom I'm busy
11 I've got about three different
businesses you know if I'm in a meeting
I need to be able to remember stuff and
recall information nootropics also known
as smart drugs appear to have had some
beginnings in Silicon Valley where
high-performing tech entrepreneurs try
to get an edge over the competition now
the trend extends to well anyone it's
hard to know officially just how many
people are taking nootropics but go
online and there are forums and podcasts
devoted to discussing them there's one
user here asking which nootropic will be
most beneficial to take while learning a
new language someone else over here is
asking which new topic would be best to
take instead of a cup of coffee in the
morning and it seems fans don't just
want to push their brains up a gear they
want mental preservation to they've seen
their parents who you know maybe had
Alzheimer's had seen al dementia kind of
seen what the you know the last decades
of life can be like as far as a
cognitive downslope and so they're
they're very um you know anxious to make
sure like you know I saw I saw what
happened to my parents I want to make
sure that doesn't happen to me some
scientists studying the effects of
cognitive enhancing drugs say there are
groups of society who could really
benefit from them air traffic
controllers doctors working at night
people in the military that way they
could keep themselves or other people
safe however we need to know that these
drugs are
if the healthy people to use in the long
term at the moment many nootropics fans
buy over the internet and with some of
the drugs that's illegal
also customers can rarely know what
they're really getting it's a very
dangerous position to take if you think
you're going to go online and get a
genuine medicine you may well not be it
could be something completely different
it could be have a different active
ingredient you could have no active
ingredient
it could have twice the potency that you
actually thought might be in there the
idea of improved brain performance
though seems to have many willing to
take that risk
Gemma Morris Sky News